hey guys in this video I'm gonna give
you ten healthy hair tips for men well
it's actually for women as well right
but I think a percent of my channel is
only men so this is actually a video
request and I don't want to waste any
more time so let's get to it I have a
dream right guys not to take good care
of your hair you need to also take care
of your scalp and both of them are
actually a lot more sensitive than you
think they are both of them need TLC to
look their best so let's start with the
first tip you gotta use less styling
products you're not saying where they
say less is more well when it comes to
your hair is definitely true don't stall
your hair every single day but give it a
few days a week just to breathe meaning
don't put any products in your hair and
then the days we need to do add products
don't go all out a little bit goes a
long way if you use the right products
sparingly don't do cold showers yes I
know there's subtle YouTube channels and
I say well cold showers is great for you
but it's not great for your hair here's
the truth cold water on your head
constrict the small blood vessels in
your skull making them less active but
they need to be active to carry the
nutrients and to do with waste products
on the skin's surface so just suddenly
hitting your head with cold water
does your scalp more harm than good so
just take a normal shower where the
water is not too hot not too cold but
just right now this tip I've answered
this in previous videos but I still got
so many questions about this so I gotta
answer this quickly and this video is
for you guys how many times should you
wash your hair in a week
short answer is just two to three times
a week it also depends on the condition
of your hair you got a lot of dandruff
then I would watch it more often to get
a dandruff up right but for normal hair
just two to three times a week is fine
if you do more than that you're going to
strip away all those healthy oils on
your hair and then with those healthy
oils gone
your hair is gonna be more dry but on
the other side of the spectrum if you
don't wash it enough it's gonna become
oily and greasy and you might also even
get dandruff now this tip is more for
guys with thinning hair but if you have
thin hair start to study right here with
Mack styling products if you enter into
your thirties 35 40s you will start to
realize that some of you are getting
thinner hair like myself so to make it
look a little bit better and thicker use
matte
styling products because matte styling
paste or clay absorbs light and make
your hair appear thicker and just so you
know I'll add food product options for
you video description of everything that
I'm talking about in this video
you gotta trim your hair more often and
at the right time because your hair will
take damage day after day and in a few
weeks it's noticeable now I personally
like my hair short because it fits me
better and so I go every three to four
weeks and I trim my hair and here's a
super tip we want to go and trim your
hair choose the right time if you want
your barber to be at ease best or her
best then timing is everything you gotta
ask for an appointment at the start or
end of the day when the salons are at
the least busiest time
be gentle you might be tough but your
hair is not so when you get out of the
shower and it's wet don't rub it dry
with a towel like this because you will
break it so remember when your hair is
wet it is at its weakest and it can
break easily so just Pat it dry gently
use a pre styling product or is that
well it's exactly what it says it is you
use it before you start your hair with
other products why is this important
because it adds protection before you
blow-dry your hair if you do blow-dry
your hair and pre styling products like
sea salt sprays mousses and serums helps
you to style your hair easier and has a
real impact on the finished style now
this one is gonna sound a little bit
strange to some of you but a lot of
models and also actors do this a lot to
have a healthy hair listen carefully
wash your hair with eggs yeah some
people only use the egg white and some
use the egg white and the egg yolk now
you can use it as a shampoo and a
conditioner in one and it will clean
your hair and your scalp and give it a
little bit of volume now you might be
thinking Daniel you serious yes I'm
serious
look eggs work as a cleaning agent
because of the list thing it has and it
has a good amount of protein that will
make your hair healthier and just
remember
rinse it off well so that you don't
smell like an egg head when you when you
go to people and you don't have to do it
but once a month is fine now this one is
also very important before you go to bed
and if you have products in your hair
wash it out remember you need to let
your hair and your skull breathe
now I know some products are stubborn so
this is what you got to do to wash it up
add shampoo while you have dry hair not
wet especially if you use wax the best
way to deal with it is to apply shampoo
to dry hair and rinse it out now you can
also wash your hair with conditioner
first before you use shampoo most
conditioners help to break down any
products start to protect your hair more
prevention is a lot better than just
trying to find treatments whenever a
condition has already worsened so if you
like swimming for example most people
don't notice but chlorine is terrible
for your hair it chemically bonds with
the protein in your hair and causes the
hairs protective outer layer called the
cuticle to lift which then causes dry
brittle and dull hair so what you can do
is just apply there stuff that you can
buy but some of them are expensive but
you can just use conditioner as well
just apply to your hair before you get
into a pool now another issue is the Sun
remember when you're outside at the pool
or anywhere outdoors remember sun damage
is terrible for your hair don't stay in
the Sun too long or use a cap that
protects your hair from sun damage
another tip is to use the right shampoo
and conditioner for your hair if you
don't know what's used and check out
this video and it's gonna help you out
I'll see you there just guys